So Mexico City is a place
of paradoxes, of conundrums,
and of water that it's
there but you don't see it.
There's parts of the cities
where you would never know
just by looking at them that there's any
water crisis around.
They have clean water 24 hours a day,
apparently just as abundant as it would be
in New York or something like that.
Then you have other parts of the city
where people are living
in very, very, extremely
precarious water situations.
Low-income parts of Mexico City
and the people that live around it
are now facing a situation
where they open the tap
and no water comes out.
It's a very tragic story of having
all of the water in the
world and somehow ending up
being a city that today is on the list
of top 10 cities most
likely to run out of water.
You have to do something, and so we do.
Enrique Lomnitz' hometown, Mexico City,
is in a water crisis that
gets worse by the day.
He started social enterprise Isla Urbana
to stem the tide.
They design and build
cheap and simple systems
that catch and clean rainwater.
There's nothing new about
rainwater harvesting.
People have been harvesting rainwater
since they first opened their mouths
and looked up at the sky at the same time.
It seemed to us like a logical thing.
Just figure out how we can use this water
that we have available to us
as kind of like a first
part of a larger solution.
It's a situation that affects
women very particularly.
Mostly it's women who tend to be more
kind of in charge of
managing the household
and basically their lives start circling
around these water issues.
Elizabeth is one of 11 people
living in this house on
the edge of Mexico City.
She's also one of 2.5 million people
who don't have access to
permanent and safe drinking water.
But going thirsty isn't where Elizabeth
and her family's problems end.
The economic implications
of not having water
are very interesting,
and the people that rely
on water trucks, for example,
they often have to have somebody at home
all the time to wait for a
possible water truck arrival
so there's often someone
that can't work at all.
They just need to always be at home.
What's strange about Mexico City, though,
is it isn't some barren desert.
It's wet. Really wet.
Here we'll have one hour
where it's like apocalyptic.
The sky is just falling and
there's lighting and thunder
and rivers in the streets.
During the rainy season
you will have floods.
Those floods can last for days.
Mexico City gets considerably more rain
than a city like London does, for example.
The question that comes to one's mind
is if we have so much water resources,
why do we have to be in
such a bad situation?
The water crisis in Mexico
City is a 400-year-old story.
Mexico City started off
being a city on an island
in the center of a lake in this basin
high up in the mountains.
And over the course of 400 years,
basically the city has focused on draining
all of these ancient
lakes out of the aquifer
and building a giant
modern city in its place.
So where you had this
2,000-square-kilometer lake
you now have just city as
far as the eye can see.
You see a lot of highways
and a lot of avenues
and streets who have the name of rivers.
Those streets were actually
rivers 50, 60 years ago.
To provide for its vast population
around 1,800 wells pump
water out of the ground,
depleting the aquifer below.
But because the city's
prone to deadly flooding
it's built a massive infrastructure
to get the water out
quickly when it rains.
The result: not enough water filters down
to recharge the aquifer.
The loss of that water
that you can actually see
is paralleled with the drying
up of all of the aquifers.
We're just pumping and
pumping and pumping water
out of the ground to the
degree that, actually,
Mexico City is physically sinking.
More than 10 meters in the last century.
Monuments need steps added
for people to reach them,
streets rise and fall,
sinkholes open up the earth,
and the water from the ground isn't enough
to quench the city's thirst.
30% of its water is imported
from outside the city.
But the infrastructure is so old and huge
not only is 40% of water
lost through leaks,
but much of what does make
it can become contaminated.
Many people end up spending
a significant portion
of their income on
expensive bottled water.
People don't trust the
quality of the water
they get out of the grid even in areas
where it's actually quite good.
98 or so percent of the population
doesn't drink tap water.
They buy water from purifiers,
from these filter stores
that will fill your five-gallon jugs.
We're industrial designers, and honestly,
we were looking for problems to solve.
People just started
telling us about water.
They started telling us about how
their water situation was
getting worse and worse.
Isla Urbana installed their first system
here in Ajusco on the
southern edge of the city.
It didn't take long for people
to realize the benefits.
Little by little almost
all of the neighbors
have started harvesting
rainwater themselves.
We're working with communities
so that they can become self-reliant
in getting their own water supply
and securing their own water.
It needs to be as simple as possible.
Rain falls on the roof,
goes through the gutters,
goes through the pipe,
diverts the first volume,
goes into a tank, gets chlorinated,
you let the little bits of dust settle
and then you pump that water out
and give it just some simple filtration.
That water you can just connect directly
into your house's existing plumbing system
so you open a tap in the kitchen
and that's the rainwater
that's coming out.
For families in these areas that are very,
very water-stressed,
starting to harvest rainwater
can mean sometimes doubling
the amount of water
that you actually have available.
95% or so of the water
that's used in a household
is not for drinking,
it's for everything else,
and so that's really
where you wanna hit first
'cause that's where you're gonna make
the biggest first difference.
So we want to have our baseline system
be as affordable as possible,
but designed in such a way
that you can add new
treatment systems to it
so that you can eventually stop
having to buy drinking water as well.
The water, it's water,
except it's just water
that's reaching your house via
falling on you from the sky
instead of coming from
the city's water grid.
We get usually between
700 and 1,000 liters
of water per year for
every square meter of roof.
So if you have a house that has, say,
a 100-square-meter roof,
it's not a huge house at all,
a house like that can get up to
around 100,000 liters of water per year.
The problem at that point becomes
they just don't have enough
tanks to store it all.
Mexico City should be able to get
at least 20 to 30% of its water demand
through rainwater harvesting systems,
which is very significant.
It's an incredible amount of water.
Guaranteeing water goes way beyond
quenching thirst and saving money.
It could also save a city from itself.
You have health, economic,
social, political problems.
If you divide the amount of water
that gets into the network every second,
every inhabitant of Mexico City
should get 350 liters per day.
If the entire eastern part of Mexico City
runs out of water there's gonna be
incredible amounts of social friction
and discontent and political crises.
We all live in this valley.
We all need to be okay.
The local government has recognized
the perilous position
the city finds itself in
and last year invested in
10,000 of Isla Urbana's systems.
They plan to install 100,000 by 2024.
Many believe regenerating areas of nature
holds the key to protecting cities
from problems like water sustainability.
We're not going to be able to return
to the Aztec city in
the middle of the lake.
That's gone.
But we can have a new
water model for the city.
A model where we keep
water, we have rivers,
we have small lakes, and water
can be a friend and an ally
and not a foe like it's today.
When it comes to running out of water,
Mexico City isn't alone.
L.A., Cape Town, Sao
Paulo, the list is growing,
each with millions of inhabitants
facing devastating water crises.
They're serving as a warning
as more of the world's population
migrates to urban centers.
Mexico City in 1940
had maybe a 1.5 million inhabitants
and today has close to 23 million people.
And this incredibly violent growth
and all this incredibly
fast expansion of the city
has put unbelievable stress
on all of the natural systems
that provide us with things like water.
Since 2009 Isla Urbana have installed
more than 20,000 of
their harvesting systems,
mostly on top of low-income
homes in Mexico City
and in rural communities.
Their devices catch a combined
800 million liters of water
each year, providing some 120,000 people
with a significant portion
of their water needs.
I believe a lot in the
empowerment aspect of this.
How do we transition to being a society
where everybody is actively participating
in water management and
is actually harvesting
their own water and taking care of it
and not relying on this other system?